it looks like voters will dismember the
democrats come november true democrats
face a blowout well unless dead people
turn out
chuck todd crunched all kinds of numbers
this week and concluded that things
ain't looking good for democrats headed
into the midterms the bottom line is
generic ballot if the democrats are
losing it means they're going to get
walloped in summary right now you've got
three essentially three numbers here
that all point into dangerous territory
for the democrats in the incumbent party
dangerous territory reminds me of the
sign outside cavuto's dressing room
nbc news has a new poll showing
republicans have a 17-point advantage
and enthusiasm with a 67 percent saying
they're very interested in the midterms
compared to just 50 of the dems people
are more enthusiastic about rectal exams
than they are about democrats although
it's a similar sensation
meanwhile do the ladies of the view
support a legislative coup
it also wants president biden to rule by
executive order which is not how our
society but he has to he can you can't
build consensus with crazy people
and how do they put the view together
finally politico reports that biden got
mixed messages from rival factions of
house dems progressives want to knock
unilaterally while moderates wanted to
play ball with republicans but as you
know he's enough trouble with one
message let alone two especially if
they're who am i and how did i get here
what's joe think oh yeah yeah yeah look
look
come on
i can make deals
i i'm a backroom guy
you know i get in close i i don't just
massage shoulders i massage hearts
and and brains
yeah yeah i'm an organ guy come on man
i'll
i'll massage your liver with a nice
chianti
you know kat um
who knew that the view was for
authoritarianism sunny sunny is not so
sunny more like gloomy am i right you
see what i did there a little wordplay
on her name that was really good yeah i
think i'm the first person to ever do
that yeah absolutely i think you should
just basically really breaking ground i
don't even know how i'm gonna answer yes
i'm incredibly intimidated
but also like isn't she's a lawyer right
yes like i knew i should have went to
law school because there's no way it can
be that hard if
she thinks that that's actually
something that makes sense you it's not
a dictatorship you can't just say
they're crazy so i'm not going to deal
with it i'm going to make whatever laws
i want but that's the exact kind of
attitude that is the problem
you know joe biden and you know
democrats are still going with yeah you
know like they're all racist they're all
transphobic and get your fourth booster
and we're the best and they're stupid
and people are like hey uh you know you
made me poor everything's so expensive i
don't have money to buy food i think
that's the kind of stuff that people are
you know focused on right exactly you
know jim you've written so much on
democrat politics i get your newsletter
it's fantastic very much i've read all
your books sometimes twice if you had
the president's ear what would you tell
him well it's like i say in my
newsletter there is no we in us yes uh i
think the democrats the problem is they
seem to
have their uh priorities a little off as
to what average people like they think
the only thing worse than hitting
somebody with a hammer is making a
mistake about their preferred pronouns
yes they're they're obsessed with
harping on language and scolding and
they don't realize that they should
focus on the important stuff like the
genitals of college swimmers
[Laughter]
this goes to your um your um your your
own uh what's the word i'm looking for
point point that you've made a number of
times about the externals yeah the
people that are that play with the
externals but they live in the external
not the internal they have first world
problems and the rest of americans have
real problems like
they're arguing over pronouns ukraine's
fighting for their lives there's there's
differences but if you ask the wrong
democrat there is no difference right
yeah so
it's one of those things it's always
nice when crazy calls somebody else
crazy so you can always feel good that
somebody completely out of their mind is
telling you you're out of your mind
which you should sleep well which means
that if she thinks i'm crazy then i'm
normal right we're good because
americans they are outraged and it's not
the little meters on red and a little
cute thing it's not
we might be in trouble you're past
trouble right we're deep i mean it might
just be i mean red wave no i mean it
might be a complete like tight red
titanic just sunk everywhere but they
have no one to blame but themselves you
attacked americans at their core you
tackled law enforcement you attacked
families
parents education and then you mess up
everybody's money
but hey we're going to make sure that
everyone's called dreamers at disneyland
thank you thank you
i feel better yeah solve the problem no
more genders at disneyland you know
degan uh chuck todd we ran uh some sound
from chuck todd
uh called it a walloping
i like that word i prefer the puffed up
overconfident
clark toad what's his name chuck todd
yes uh
and i that applies to democrats and the
tv jack jaws like where then when they
get shellacked that's when they're you
get to watch their pomposity melt into
horror and shame like one of my favorite
days of my entire life was november 9th
early wednesday morning 2016 coming to
work driving by the javits center where
hillary clinton didn't show up and all
these people like sitting on the curb
crying
like somebody had thrown their barbie
doll into the fireplace
that just makes me feel warm on the
inside thinking about it i've thrown a
few barbies
on the barbie
you know what greg i almost have a
respect for sonny and i'm not just
saying that because she's hot
come on jim
but uh no i almost respect the honesty
of what she said because that's
emotionally how everybody feels yeah
it's asinine but it's how we all feel if
your person's in charge why can't they
just do it yeah yeah yeah it's like i
want an executive order every day right
you know yeah so she's not like it's
stupid but every person who likes the
person in charge feels like just just
make it happen not me i want like total
anarchy yeah i wouldn't mind that either
but she's fun to negotiate with at home
she has a job because she is capable of
sitting in her chair and not falling on
the floor yeah yes that's true but also
sunny she's bright
i mean i don't want to stop
[Laughter]
yes coming up will cnn plus become a cnn
bust hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else